[Música]
hola soy santiago lópez gonzález por
natalia cabrera y esto es aqui américa
el espacio de france 24 en el que
revisamos y profundizamos en las
historias y las noticias de nuestro
continente
en esta edición vamos a ir a venezuela
el gobierno de nicolás maduro le dio 72
horas para abandonar el país a la
embajadora de la unión europea esto en
respuesta a las recientes sanciones que
bruselas le impuso a 19 funcionarios de
alto rango del gobierno venezolano en
ecuador son 79 los reclusos que
fallecieron en tres cárceles en motines
que enfrentaron a diferentes bandas
criminales las autoridades ya
catalogaron estos motines como los
peores en la historia carcelaria de
ecuador- y emma coronel la esposa del
narcotraficante mexicano joaquín el
chapo guzmán fue capturada en eeuu
coronel ya compareció por presunta
participación en tráfico internacional
de drogas en una primera audiencia ante
un juez estadounidense que a su vez le
dictaminó prisión sin derecho a fianza
por haber conspirado con su esposo para
dirigir una organización criminal
[Música]
vamos con nuestra historia principal de
esta edición de aquí américa el inicio
de la semana estuvo marcado por la
reunión de los ministros de asuntos
exteriores de la unión europea que
aprobaron sanciones contra 19 altos
funcionarios del gobierno de nicolás
maduro en venezuela esto eleva ya a 55
el total de funcionarios y personas
cercanas a maduro sancionadas por
bruselas entre ellas está del si
rodríguez la actual vicepresidenta desde
miraflores rechazaron esta medida
los 27 países de la unión europea
sancionan de nueva o venezuela las
medidas restrictivas de este lunes se
aplican sobre 19 funcionarios y altos
cargos del gobierno de nicolás maduro
cifra que eleva 55 de las personas
sancionadas en un comunicado de los
ministros de asuntos exteriores europeos
dijeron los individuos añadidos a la
lista son responsables en particular de
menoscabar los derechos electorales de
la oposición y el funcionamiento
democrático de la asamblea nacional y
por serias violaciones de los derechos
humanos y restricciones de libertades
fundamentales
las nuevas sanciones implican la
prohibición de entrar al territorio
comunitario y la congelación de los
activos y bienes que tengan en la unión
europea'
en una intervención virtual durante la
inauguración de las sesiones del consejo
de derechos humanos de la onu el
mandatario venezolano respondió así como
también ratificó que no aceptaremos la
injerencia o intervención de ningún
mecanismo inquisidor contra nuestra
patria venezuela que pretenda usar la
justa causa de los derechos humanos
herramienta política para un cambio de
gobierno un cambio de régimen por la
fuerza en nuestro país maduro dijo
además que la congelación de sus activos
representa una amenaza para la lucha
contra la pandemia de kobe 19 venezuela
ha sido privada de al menos 30 mil
millones de dólares en efectivo que
forma parte de los activos de la
republica en el exterior recursos que
debieron y deben ser utilizados para
atender la salud la alimentación y los
derechos integrales de nuestro pueblo
las sanciones llegan después de que el
bloque europeo expresara que las
elecciones parlamentarias del pasado 6
de diciembre en venezuela- ganadas por
el chavismo no cumplieron los estándares
democráticos los 27 no reconocen al
actual parlamento y se han mostrado
partidarios de trabajar con el líder de
la oposición juan guaidó para poder
celebrar nuevos comicios en el país y
respaldar los mecanismos de solución
alcón y la respuesta desde caracas a
estas sanciones no se hizo esperar y el
gobierno de nicolás maduro le dio
entre dos horas para abandonar el país
hay saber brillante la embajadora del
bloque comunitario en ese país
suramericano también la declaró persona
no grata
bruselas lamentó esta decisión y pidió
revertirlo
persona 'non grata' así declaró el
gobierno venezolano a la embajadora de
la unión europea en caracas como
respuesta a las nuevas sanciones que el
bloque europeo impuso contra el país
socialista esta semana ahora la
diplomática isabel brillante tiene 72
horas para abandonar el país y otros
cuatro diplomáticos europeos en caracas
han recibido avisos en contra del fallo
de bruselas se le da un plazo de 72
horas para abandonar el territorio
venezolano y lo hacemos
porque las circunstancias así lo exigen
lo hacemos porque van ya 55 decisiones
eso que llaman en la unión europea o en
el sistema estadounidense sanciones como
si tuviese en ellos alguna autoridad
moral que no la tienen ni tampoco legal
para imponer castigo alguno
a ciudadanos de cualquier otro país que
no sean del propio territorio de la
unión europea la unión europea lamentó
la decisión del ejecutivo venezolano y
dijo que el movimiento sólo contribuía
al aislamiento de la nación sudamericana
el bloque europeo decidió imponer nuevas
sanciones como el congelamiento de
bienes e impedimentos de viajes contra
19 oficiales venezolanos que incluyen a
la vicepresidenta delfín rodríguez y al
segundo al mando del gobierno diosdado
cabello
la razón socavar la democracia y cometer
abusos contra los derechos humanos todo
a raíz de las elecciones a la asamblea
nacional del pasado diciembre en las que
ganó maduro pero que ni la unión europea
ni eeuu reconocen en medio de una
profunda crisis económica y social
maduro se ha mostrado abierto a negociar
con la unión europea para levantar las
sanciones que calificó de crueles e
injustas no obstante esta decisión aleja
la posibilidad de futuras conversaciones
entre caracas y bruselas
los motines recientes en las cárceles
ecuatorianas los peores en la historia
de ese país según las autoridades dejan
hasta el momento 79 personas fallecidas
y un número indeterminado de heridos los
enfrentamientos comenzaron por las
luchas internas entre bandas criminales
que se disputan el control territorial
dentro de los centros de reclusión la
otra cara de la moneda son los
familiares de los fallecidos que todavía
están esperando respuestas
dolor e incertidumbre fuera de este
penal de guayaquil los familiares
esperan a las puertas del centro
penitenciario respuestas sobre la
situación de los internos después de una
violenta jornada de disturbios dentro de
tres carteles del ecuador
que deja más de 70 muertos
no nos dicen nada solo dice que ya está
tranquilo está tranquilo pero adentro
dicen que no debo está el problema y no
nos dan ninguna respuesta no nos dan
ninguna respuesta para nosotros estar un
poco más tranquilo me entiende ellos
tienen vídeos no sé cómo le han llegado
vídeos de personas en el piso muertas
tantas cosas que se ven y creo que uno
de los carteles de cuadros se
encontraban en una situación crítica
pero en los últimos años la violencia
interna se ha convertido en una
constante hasta que el martes la lucha
entre dos bandas criminales por mantener
el liderazgo se salió de control
desatando motines simultáneos en tres
penales del país que aglutina la 70% de
la población carcelaria de ecuador según
las autoridades la situación está ahora
bajo control o de que el ejército fuera
desplegado para sofocar la revuelta
hemos tenido hoy el apoyo frontal de
policía nacional alrededor de 800
servidores policiales entre oficiales
clases y policías han apoyado para
y poder controlar
y poner nuevamente
el orden dentro de los centros de
privación de la libertad los grupos de
derechos humanos atacan la escalada de
violencia a las deficiencias en el
sistema penitenciario ecuatoriano con
capacidad para albergar a 29 mil
reclusos el panorama real es una
población interna de 38 mil personas y
1.500 guardias para supervisarlos
coronel la esposa del narcotraficante
mexicano joaquín el chapo guzmán fue
detenida en un aeropuerto en eeuu la
mujer era buscada por presunta
participación en tráfico internacional
de drogas coronel ya compareció en una
primera audiencia ante un tribunal del
distrito de columbia que le dictaminó
prisión sin derecho a fianza por haber
conspirado con su esposo para dirigir
una organización criminal
la esposa del jefe del mayor cartel de
la droga en méxico fue detenida en más
coronel aispuro fue arrestada en un
aeropuerto cerca washington
coronel aispuro enfrenta a un cargo
criminal por conspiración para
distribuir un kilogramo o más de heroína
cinco kilogramos o más de cocaína 1000
kilogramos o más de marihuana y 500
gramos o más de metanfetaminas para su
importación ilegal a eeuu la joven de 31
años también es acusada de haber ayudado
a su esposo a escapar de una prisión
mexicana de máxima seguridad en 2015
joaquín el chapo guzmán salió por un
túnel de un kilómetro y medio cavado
desde la ducha de su celda tras ser
detenido nuevamente coronel habría
colaborado en un nuevo escape para su
marido conocido por su sed de sangre y
tácticas violentas que incluían golpear
y disparar contra sus rivales
guzmán es considerado el narcotraficante
más poderoso desde pablo escobar en 2017
tras su tercer arresto fue extraditado a
eeuu dos años después fue condenado a
cadena perpetua en un juicio nueva york'
durante el proceso coronel se convirtió
en el centro de interés de los medios de
comunicación con sus trajes de diseñador
y la lealtad que le mostró a su esposo
cuando los fiscales detallaron que el
chapo tuvo múltiples amantes y nos vamos
a colombia la oficina del alto
comisionado de la onu para los derechos
humanos informó que en 2020 en ese país
suramericano se produjeron 76 masacres
en las que fueron asesinadas 292
personas el organismo instó al gobierno
del presidente iván duque a mejorar la
protección de los defensores de los
derechos humanos que se han convertido
en las principales víctimas de estos
ataques
el último informe del alto comisionado
de naciones unidas para los derechos
humanos revela que en colombia en 2020
se produjeron 76 masacres en las que
murieron 292 personas entre las víctimas
mortales se encuentran 6 niñas y 18
niños se trata de la cifra más alta
registrada por el organismo desde 2014
en varias partes del país hubo una
intensificación de la violencia y un
aumento en el control territorial y
social por parte de grupos armados no
estatales y grupos criminales con
nefastas consecuencias para los derechos
humanos además alertó que la violencia
en diversas partes del país obligó a más
de 25 mil personas a desplazarse la
situación es además especialmente
crítica para los defensores de los
derechos humanos en el pasado año se
registraron 133 asesinatos de activistas
25 más que en el año anterior la onu
instó al gobierno colombiano a mejorar
la protección de los defensores de los
derechos humanos y a repuntar su
presencia en áreas remotas del país
le pidió cumplir el acuerdo de paz
firmado en 2016 por el gobierno de juan
manuel santos con la entonces guerrilla
de las farc la agencia de la onu lamentó
el asesinato de 248 combatientes que
dejaron las armas tras el pacto e indicó
que estas muertes se deben a la ausencia
del estado en territorios vulnerables
instó asimismo a desmantelar grupos
armados de distinto tipo como los de ex
guerrilleros de las farc que rechazaron
el acuerdo militantes de otras
guerrillas y bandas criminales dirigidas
por paramilitares considerados los
principales culpables del asesinato de
activistas
y terminamos con las primeras imágenes
enviadas desde el planeta marte por el
vehículo espacial perseverance las
imágenes corresponden a un vídeo de tres
minutos grabado por cinco cámaras que
muestran el momento en que este vehículo
espacial se posa en la superficie y
levanta una buena cantidad de arena
rojiza la nasa también publicó un
archivo de audio del sonido de la
superficie y también del viento de este
planeta este vehículo espacial se espera
oeste 10 años en el planeta rojo
gracias por acompañarme en esta edición
de aquí américa recuerde que puede
seguirnos a través de las redes sociales
y también en la página web france24
puntocom
soy santiago lópez gonzález por natalia
cabrera hasta la próxima
[Música]